في المقابل للقال المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه يوري اجناد ان الاراضي
الاوكرانيه تعرضت الليله الماضيه لهجوم
الروسيا بقاذفات استراتيجيه من طراز 22
واكد اجناس اسقاط طائره مسيره في سماء
كييف وخمس مسيرات في مناطق اخرى من
اوكرانيا خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضيه
لكي نظر شهدت الليله الماضيه هجوما قويا
جنه طائرات روسيه بعيده المدى من طراز 22
طائرتان اقلعتان من مطار انجلز وخمس من
شاي كيدغا هذا هو المكان الذي تتمركز فيه
هذه القاذفات وقد اطلقوا صواريخ من طراز
22 فوق اراضينا بشكل ارهابي وهذه الصواريخ
تسمى بقاتل حاملات الطائرات وقد اطلق
المعتدون سته صواريخ من هذا الطراز لكنهم
لم يحققوا اهدافهم يستخدم العدو ما تبقى
لديه من صواريخ من الحقبه السوفيتيه
للحفاظ على ما لديه من صواريخ عاليه الدقه
كصواريخ كاليبر